all right let's give this guy
another
shot here computer impossible two games
and i don't really get to see e4 played
by the computer so often
hmm i'm gonna go for the french try and
get a closed position
hmm
okay
let's see
let's go with the bishop e7 i want to
get in d5 i've
played the black side
against the computer out of this french
defense
many times and sometimes it castles
queen side and could get rolled right
over believe it or not
let's see if it makes that poor decision
alright so
phase one or at least a step in the
direction
positions closed in the center
and now that's very awkward
queen here huh
what's the story with that so
let me try to play two games against
this
beast
i'm thinking just c5 and then i'm
already threading threatening d4
not quite sure what the problem is with
that there's always some tricky stuff
with knight takes pawn and then some
pawn push but i don't believe that's
working
and i don't know that i want to commit
myself to hang on commit myself to
kingside castle
if c4 knight here is that going to be a
pain
sometimes does stuff like that
it makes it difficult to get that pawn
back i'm going to go with c5
yeah that's a lot of queen moves
e2 e3 f4
okay
well i'd better just get developed put
pressure on this guy he was not easily
defended wow one two three four queen
moves
okay
well what do we do here
i'm gonna castle
bishop h6 one day could happen but
and that's maybe
being lined up right now so do i play
king h8 or do i ignore and play f6 try
and open up the position i do have a
lead in development
could also think about putting pressure
on this pawn
hmm you know the queen the most natural
defender of c2 has
clearly gone astray so knight b4 ideas
spring to mind
but i might want to just invest one move
with king to h8
hmm
and then maybe do this one one move
later this is very awkward
d3 i mean he's i could definitely
anticipate bishop to e2 happening
i'm just gonna go with king h8 invest
one move i i certainly can do that with
all the different
moves uh by the white queen so i think
white is really getting ready to
queenside castle and i don't believe
that's the correct
way to go but
all right
well
i'm going to try and prepare not only
this
not only stop night here to here but i
want to get these guys going
if i played knight before rook there was
available
all right let's set this guy in motion
bishop b7 maybe i give him a kick okay
we're castled on the same side
uh do i really have a better spot for my
bishop than b7 probably not let's get
there
and all right you stopped my
pawn push idea
what i really would have liked to have
happen is knight to b6 and then b4 to
stop
knight a4
um
all right well what's the other pawn
break in the position probably on the f6
that really weakens this e6 pawn
okay night here knight takes pawn takes
and then and then the knight has to go
where
not quite sure maybe i could set that up
let's get my rook here and then this
move is maybe threatened
okay if i go here now he can't be taken
because of pawn takes then i win on c2
i'm lacking some space
so i'm probably a bit welcome to some
exchanges let's do this
oh
all right what about just capture
knight f5 the queen moves out of the way
i'm probably running into g4 as
weakening as that is
computer has no fear
i think i'm okay with exchanging my
queen knight for their king knight he's
kind of
not going to be doing anything exciting
is he
we'll see about that
okay
now immediately i tend to focus on this
square here
with some possible sacrifices i do have
enough support for again i'm always
looking for this
capture here and then if i'm ever
recapturing this e6 idea but i don't
think it's there
so i'd really like to maybe
how about i get another night here
yeah i think i have time to do that and
i don't know that i want to
push my
think i'm okay well maybe now i do
since a question is being thrown to my
pawn and i don't want the a file to open
up i'm under a minute
okay
maybe
i should
first
develop my queen his bishop here can be
played now let's get my knight here
41 seconds
plenty of time okay
um
queen
d7
i guess
queen d7 yeah what's what's the big plan
here
i really don't know
this knight oh knight g3 to h5
that could be
annoying
hmm
20 seconds um
how about
all right i'm setting up f6 eventually
i don't have a good feeling about this
uh let's do this
back my bishop up and then get my knight
into this square
i like a light square bishop exchange i
really do
and now i'm going to plant my knight
right here in the center and i'll have
ooh
all right this is what i was going to
say
um
i really like my knight but
i'm gonna take this guy out oh i'm gonna
get hit with a fork a bishop here is
strong
oh okay well
let me let me go here
wow not a lot of time back up my bishop
hmm
let's get here
f6 and then pawn push let's just seal
this up seven seconds
are they trying to beat me on time
i'm gonna win this pun
i love winning puns yeah i got exactly
what i would want
this is beautiful closed position can i
convert it
let's just trade
guard some light squares
get my queen here
watch out for any tactics i just want to
get my queen here queen trade please
seven seconds i better not lose on time
um
look here pawn push that weakens this
right here how am i doing on time
oh no
i really didn't want to have to do this
but i want to stop f4
it's very weakening yes it is
oh no
king here
something hap something's happening here
oh my goodness
3.3 pawn push come over here
an accident an accident's gonna happen
and i could feel it oh my goodness
exactly what i didn't want to have
happen oh i'm down
oh i had
oh man i'm
speechless okay yeah it opened up i
didn't have time
yeah you know what that means
i'll have to play different time control
right no
i love five two even if it's
me running short on time ah man i was up
that pond why'd it have to open up
all i wanted was a queen trade
that's all i needed and it would have
been smooth sailing
yeah right
okay well
who cares about that game right we're
onto this one the last one
and i'm comfortable again i love these
positions
get rid of the dark square bishop
bad bishop versus good bishop exchange
ah man
i guess i'm having still difficulty
shaking that game off
okay
what about
capture refocus here you got plenty of
time
okay
you're gonna do
takes takes and then e5 is that what
you're lining up
let's take this guy out let's see how
you recapture before i make a decision
with my c4 pawn okay fine
fine
now what about just capture yeah let's
let's clarify the center i'm opening up
this door for the bishop
i don't want to have to deal with e5 i
want to try and play one day against
this guy
where's my bishop along probably here
bishop e2
just to sidestep any pin
okay he's going there anyway
yes it is a he
i can never shake that off
computers are all he's
okay h3
knight a4 to c5
which knight is gonna blink first is the
big question he moves
maybe i move my knight he moves maybe i
move my king knight
okay they're both
these uh these knights are counterparts
f3
c6
c3 f6 what do i do
h3
a3
to keep out a knight or a queen from
going here that's not two annoying i'm
not quite sure
hm what type of exchanges
would i welcome here
i really don't want to have the light
square bishops being exchanged
but that's likely going to happen
let's give them a kick
see what blacks can do should probably
just back up no
whoo
i like that
okay i have pressure here
where does my queen belong
what about
yeah what about here now that this
square is covered a bit with my bishop
maybe i could go in for this move
yeah i'll give it a shot knight a4 to c5
yeah
it's dancing back and forth
that's the big old plan isn't it knight
c5
yeah i really like my position i like my
last game's position too
okay this is a good square for a knight
yeah i don't think black knows what he's
doing
um
hmm
like i could fire away at this night
double up triple up
it's not going to be easy let's go here
i am prepared to give up my bishop for
the knight if he goes here and now my
plan was rook c2 and just double up on
the c file
let's see
no no no no no right here
yeah i think that's okay i want to i
want to get out of the way of this move
so he needs to be taken
now pawn takes i expected that
i'm going to gain a tempo against the
rook
and then i'm gonna do what oh man
there's this being set up because of the
pressure on my knight knight takes pawn
is being threatened right now
hmm
sneakyness
g3
or just
remove the knight
um
there might be a reason to keep my
knight on f4 because if i move him
knight b4 to d3 from f4 he's guarding
this so
should i go with the g3
g3 he's just gonna get kicked
i'm gonna go here maybe i could play to
c1 to watch over these squares yeah i
think
i should probably do that
maybe immediate let's see first kick the
knight
see where he wants to go if he goes here
i'm going to challenge him immediately
let's give him a kick is he going to go
here
or here uh-huh
okay now
i'm gonna just back up how we doing on
the clock
let's just go here i want to challenge
that knight soon
very very soon
g2 is hit
let's get rid of that knight before i
get killed
knight takes i take my queen to get out
of this pin
okay i got pressure on c7 ah
i love that move
um
what's better than
doubled major pieces tripled
okay where does my king belong
h1 or f1 if i go to f1 the queen's gonna
sneak back over and try and get here
what about king h2
hmm
just running into a check
i want a queen trade
as usual
king f1 or king h1
let's just go
here
i'm running into czech land
after a check i'll go to h1 okay what's
the queen lining up
oh man
what about
queen here hitting the pond and maybe
even looking to return
um
how do i make progress
queen here
i think i need my queen i'm going to
drop my queen back
defend here and yeah you got nothing you
really have nothing
um let's try this break with b5
i guess
rook here maybe
hmm
let me try this i could transfer my
other pieces
over here i want to target that pun
um
no
don't drop your queen like that
i would have screamed i definitely would
have screamed right there
okay let's grab a pond gotta get that
guy back
some trades please
not quite sure why i did that
last move
um
okay now i'm gonna do this and get here
or here
we'll see
king here
how are we looking on the clock
yeah fiend kettled queen
watch out for that
six seconds
not quite sure what that last move was
doing
um
how about queen f1
still watching over h3
there's ideas of maybe that
just they're just floundering
uh what about queen b5 that seems super
active yes now i have more safety over
here for my king
throwing a check
queen trade get my king over 10 seconds
plenty of time whoo
um
i just want to trade just a little bit
pawn push no
what would that even be doing
positions opening up just like the last
game i'm having flashbacks
having flashbacks
oh i'm gonna get it checked
pawn push f3
oh my goodness my second rank is exposed
i hate that
oh rook here is gonna kill me
again
oh
man i'm done
man
i really liked
both games the positions i had that
happens too often though doesn't it
oh man what can you do
well i'm not going to play it anymore i
have to go back to the drawing board
basically
um
not sure what to say
i really like this position as soon as i
saw
g6 i was really excited to see g6 but
how could i have gotten a trade in there
i just wanted one pair of rooks off
man couldn't i have just managed one
trade well yeah you bum what about
rook to a2 right here that would welcome
a trade
you know i was fixated on trying to get
back over here
c file should have done this
yeah if i did this
reptakes
just as a hypothetical rook takes queen
takes if rook here
well i don't know about this i don't
know that i want both rooks oops i don't
know that i would want both rooks off
this is this is a problem
yeah i just want one pair of rooks off
not two
and then try and weasel in somehow
you know oh another thing i could have
done
come to think of it now that that g5
move was played instead of king g2
probably just h4
make that a little bit more difficult to
get in and who knows maybe even the
computer would play h5 which means that
the position won't open up or expose my
king
it's uh
it could definitely i could definitely
see it do moves like that but
what can you do as soon as that break
happened and my second rank was exposed
i couldn't do anything oh well
well i'll give it a shot maybe for
another time but
that's all for
right now these are the only two games
i'm going to play and as always i hope
you got something out of it take care
bye
you